after uh 40 years of study
from a scholarly standpoint uh
that uh liberal democracy is uh
the best way and i believe the only way
to
fully ensure human dignity
[Music]
larry diamond thank you so much for
joining me on 20 minute leaders
great to be with you wonderful okay
larry a
senior fellow at hoover institute senior
fellow the freedman spogli institute at
stanford university beautiful background
behind you
we've known each other for quite some
time now uh most
prominently through the incredible class
the spirit of democracy
uh that you taught me in the beginning
of the year which gave me a 10-week
deep dive into what is democracy what is
the amazing work
uh that you've been doing there with
your colleagues
and i can't wait for this 20 minutes to
talk about democracy
and where we're headed and as a world so
maybe just give me a little bit of brief
down of
who are you and why are you even
interested in democracy
well i'm a senior fellow at uh the
institution over my shoulder the hoover
institution
on war revolution and peace and at the
freeman spogly institute
i'm a professor by courtesy of political
science and sociology at stanford and i
co-edit
uh the journal of democracy and
obviously i care about democracy i
believe in
freedom and individual dignity and
i have always believed from a
philosophical standpoint
but now i know uh after uh
40 years of study from a scholarly
standpoint
uh that uh liberal democracy
is uh the best way and i believe the
only way to
fully ensure human dignity okay so
you're saying
i heard freedom i heard human dignity
and then liberal democracy
why is there the word liberal in front
of the word democracy
well you had earlier hoped that i would
define democracy
so let me do it in this way a democracy
is a system of government in which
people can choose their leaders and
replace their leaders in free and fair
elections
if you don't have that you can't get
real political accountability maybe you
can pressure
on a semi-authority regime but
without the ability to remove leaders
who misperform
and put competing policy options
to the citizenry in
regular free and fair elections you
can't
ensure political accountability and you
are very likely to slide
rapidly down the path of tyranny and
abuse of power and abuse of human rights
at the same time the political dimension
of competition and accountability
through the let's be honest fairly crude
and limited
instrument indispensable though it is
of regular free and fair elections is
not enough
and the liberal dimension is everything
else
it's ensuring that you have very
extensive rights
of speech press association
that you have a strong rule of law in
which the courts
are fully independent that you have a
strong
constitutional order that will
defend human dignity and provide at
least
means to correct the kinds of abuses of
human rights that
we're now seeing in too many american
cities targeted against african
americans in particular
and that you know you can at least
pursue the goal difficult
though it is to achieve of social
uh economic and uh political equality
and uh you know some reasonable degree
of justice
right so so a big part of it is the
people's wish right the people's
uh vote and the people's the human
dignity and
a huge part of that is information
is the dissemination of information if
we look 20 30 years ago
there was one or two at channels in
which information was disseminated
pretty countable in a lot of areas in
the world of is that
information accurate or not now
every kid with a tick tock account or an
instagram or a facebook those are news
channels
they're not they're no longer social
media channels to me they're news
channels because
i consider myself an educated being i
i i'm all about democracy and i'm all
about information
i get so much of my news from my social
media feeds even without knowing it
just because it's there so what are the
what are some of the biggest challenges
that you've seen over the past 40 years
going forward
with how do we deal with this
information around the world you know
especially considering
the 2016 elections and the different and
the upcoming election and so on
well there's the uh eternal challenge
of ensuring freedom of information and a
plurality of information
it's not just that people have access to
information
there needs to be the freedom to gather
report convey distill
and opinionate in terms of information
and i say it's an eternal challenge
because once again
we're seeing a war on independent media
often a deadly one by autocrats around
the world who don't want to be held
accountable don't want to have their
corruption and
abuse of power exposed i believe there
was just
a prime minister who almost tried to get
a journalist into jail
in a specific country that i'm related
with but
well and uh you know israel
is uh not even close to being
uh the worst offender even among uh
so-called democracies not to mention all
the other countries of the middle east
but we're seeing pressure on the
independent media even in countries that
have been considered
liberal democracies and i'm sorry to say
that now we have a president of the
united states who has contempt for
independent media
has called them purveyors of fake news
and enemies of the people
and this gives succour comfort comfort
and uh encouragement to autocrats around
the world who want to
subdue and completely control
independent media
what is your reaction to this and
political scientists like yourselves
who are watching as you know the leader
of the free world
is perhaps moving steering very rapidly
away from
the so-called liberal democracy which
we're aiming for
well i have been ever since uh
his illiberal and
um populist
election campaign in 2015-2016
and in particular since he assumed the
presidency and began to
bring these themes of
disinformation uh intolerance
contempt for opposition contempt
for independent institutions and
independent media into the white house
i've been increasingly
disturbed uh angered uh
and horrified by by what he's been doing
i think
increasingly it represents a
danger not only to our democratic values
but to our institutions which you see
in the way he's been running roughshod
over separation of powers misusing the
military misusing the just
justice department dividing the country
firing inspectors general
and anyone who would try to hold him and
his administration to account
so i think civil society here and
elsewhere needs to stand up to this
and people from across the political
spectrum
need to rally behind
common principles bedrock minimum
principles of not just democracy but
liberal democracy
which include tolerance pluralism
respect for the independence of the
media civil society
and accountability institutions and a
rule of law but michael i did not want
to neglect the other half of your
question
which revolves around the new era we are
in with social media
and that challenge uh is fresh
because before we thought it was enough
to just have independent media
they would constitute a
an arena of uh pluralism of information
and contestation of
ideas and maybe there would be uh
some irresponsibility and sensationalism
in the midst of it but people would kind
of ferret it out
in the era of social media with the
extraordinary precision and power of
targeting uh micro targeting
uh and the algorithms that the social
media platforms generate to do this
and the anonymity of uh many of the
purveyors of this information
or as we saw in the 2016 election
campaign the deliberate disguising
of the sources of this disinformation
we're really in a new and much more
dangerous era
how it's okay so so that's i mean it's
sad to think that but
i'm i'm now thinking ahead okay so i'm
in the realm of the
millennial generation or or generation z
and y
what is our responsibility here because
honestly i think that most of the people
that i'm around
we can all vouch for democracy don't
really know what democracy is i'm very
fortunate to have
been in your class and to have listened
to you passionately
explain to us also the amazing work that
i would love to get to the american one
room
work that you've done but but what is
our responsibility now
as educated young adults who are
entering the workforce and
except for the you know act of voting
that once every four years what what do
we need to do
in order to ensure that we're moving in
the right direction because it sounds
like this is now
a a nationwide arena it's no longer just
the politicians that have to work it out
amongst themselves
well let me first come to the
information and then i'll come to the
action
um we all need to be better educated
uh and better informed and to be well
informed to be intelligently informed
and i'd say to be responsibly informed
in a democracy we can't be passively
informed and by passively i mean
allow the main or principle or
only sources of our information to be
what is conveyed to us
inc increasingly i repeat through micro
targeting in algorithmic algorithmic
formulas that constrain what we're
getting
and give us what they think is going to
entertain or outrage us but fixate our
attention
on their website and so we need to be
proactive
to seek out multiple sources of
information
and to you know check and verify
the information we're getting which
means getting on
uh others engaging in creative and
intensive
uh uh information searches to check out
assertions
and uh try to assess and validate the
authenticity
and credibility of some of the claims
that are being made before we reach
retweet them repeat them or
uh post them on our various social media
sites is that feasible to ask of a 20
year old to
yes it uh i think we can ask ask it of a
15 year old
uh and um if you doubt me
uh please interview my colleague in the
school of education sam weintraub
who has been um uh
working to um
develop protocols and educational tools
for uh sam weinberg excuse me
develop educational tools for
young people to learn how to
confirm or assess or validate the claims
they're seeing on the internet and not
just swallow them wholesale
yeah and therefore become at least
unwitting
uh purveyors of misinformation
uh but in addition on the action side
michael
don't dismiss the importance of that
voting once every four years
it's the last line of defense for
uh political accountability good
governance
uh and you know the protection of civil
liberties
but in addition we've seen we've seen it
in the last two weeks
uh since the murder of george floyd
uh in uh minneapolis
that civil society action peaceful
non-violent
disciplined coordinated impassioned
civil society action
can make a difference and can bring
about social change we saw it in the
civil rights movement in the united
states
we we saw it with the women's uh
suffragist movement in the united states
you saw it with the anti-war movement
uh in the united states and i think we
are entering a period of profound
creative renewing social and political
reform in the united states
that gives me a lot of optimism and
larry one of the main thing
things that we were discussing in in our
sessions was the
this idea of polarization and how do we
how do we bring people together of
polarized opinions
into the same room and to be able to
have educated discussions
and and to really listen and not just to
be
present and you ran a fascinating
experiment you can call it or
i think it's it's much greater than just
an experiment and
the word experiment doesn't give justice
to to the amazing world that you and
and and professor fishkin did america in
one room
bringing together people from all
different sides
talk to me about that what was that
about well i was privileged to be part
of a very
imaginative and far-reaching exercise in
dallas texas last year
uh led by my colleague uh james fishkin
uh in the department of communication at
stanford
uh to bring 526
randomly selected americans of all
ethnicities
and parties and ideological persuasions
and
diverse places in the united states
together
for much of four days
to deliberate uh on some of the major
issues facing the united states in terms
of health care the economy
uh immigration the environment and
foreign policy
and this was another iteration of the
model of deliberative polling
that jim fishkin has developed and
applied
over a hundred times in more than a
dozen countries
wow and what we found is what jim
and his deputy director alice sue of the
center for deliberative democracy and
others
have found when they've done these
things that when you bring
people together under good conditions
where they have access to
well-researched and balanced
issue briefing papers and where they can
hear
different points of view in plenary
sessions on the issues
and where they can interact and talk
about the issues
respectfully in small groups with people
who come from different places and may
have different opinions
their opinions change and we found
generally on a lot of issues not all but
on a striking number
of issues that people
that polarization reduced on the issues
on there was changed
toward less polarization with
republicans and democrats progressives
and conservatives
coming together either by moving more
toward one position than the other
or moving towards some you know kind of
creative common ground
and not least michael uh in importance
when people got to know one another
we had people who said you know i've
never uh
an african-american woman who said i've
never interacted with
like this with with a white person
before
and vice versa or a white person you
know from a rural area
um they see them as human beings
and affective polarization this
emotional
tribalism attenuates and that's very
important for the future of our
democracy
i think one of the most touching
questions from the survey afterwards
that i
really resonated with was how it was it
wasn't exactly that but it was around
how do you think the other side is
willing to listen to you
it was of that nature yeah that was a
dramatic shift all of a sudden you see
uh republicans who who are shifting and
saying yeah democrats are
are was listening to us democrats are
saying the same things about republicans
and to me that was much more powerful
than any shift on any
topic it was about this essence of are
we willing to
collaborate with the other side to
acknowledge the differences but
acknowledge that at the end we're all
citizens of this wonderful country of
this wonderful world
and we have a shared responsibility to
reach a resolution and
to better the lives of all the citizens
i can't believe
20 minutes is almost up i have to leave
with the last questions
it always sucks that it ends so quickly
and i only get about a third of what i
want to talk about
but larry i would love to hear three
words that you would describe yourself
as or if i would ask
any of your students how would they
describe larry diamond as
well uh you'll have to ask them but i
would describe
myself uh first as a democrat
with a small d i believe deeply that
liberal democracy
is um uh the best form of government
and a precondition for achieving social
justice and human dignity
i'm very uh proud of the coincidence
that uh my parents left me unwittingly
uh that my initials larry diamond are
the same initials as liberal democracy
but secondly um i am a reformer
i am an activist i'm not a revolutionary
but i do believe
we need to struggle for change and third
i think of myself as a scholar but most
of all as a teacher
uh trying to convey these ideas both to
my students and
a wider community of students around the
world so thank you for giving me an
opportunity to do it here no no larry
and i wanna i wanna use this opportunity
to thank you again
for the incredible inspiration that
you've provided me personally and
everybody else in my classes and i'm
sure that you teach at stanford
i'll never forget the very first session
it was monday morning the first quarter
of my freshman year
and i walk into the spirit of democracy
class and you're standing in front of us
talking about what the class will be
about and within about five or six
minutes you
go on you go down the path of the
america in one room and we see
the passion in your eyes and i believe
you even started tearing up a little bit
and we looked at each other afterwards
and we said
wow so this is where we came to and so i
want to thank you for that
for that inspiration and i'll take that
with me wherever i go
and and and i look forward to
maintaining this relationship over
many many years me too thank you michael
take care bye-bye
you